sie haben für 1 km Wand hier hingestellt
mit 7 Millionen Euro alles gut bei ihm
oder ja nicht mehr
aber warum was soll das in der Nacht hat
man einen halben Meter vor dem Fenster
draußen nicht mehr als 45 DBA
Schalldruck oder darf man haben so wenn
es Gewerbe Lärm ist wenn es jetzt zum
Beispiel Straßenverkehrslärm wäre
dürften es 55 dB sein
da jetzt die Laster von der öffentlichen
Straße hier auf dem privates Grundstück
fahren was ein Gewerbegrundstück ist
werden sie in dem Moment wo sie über die
Grenze fahren ungesund weil dann werden
sie gewerbelehren um die Dimension mal
zu verstehen 70 Quadratmeter Wohnung
wird durch das Ding bei einer sehr
konservativen Verzinsung 28 € teurer
jeden Monat ein Leben